there's a lot of uh right-wing people
who were against cancel culture 5 years
ago who are now saying you know what we
really need to do is to find the
relatives of every idiot student who
signed you know who belonged to a group
who signed a letter saying that Hamas is
great and make sure they never work
again in America what I'm hoping out of
this
paroxismo on the left and it's you know
groups like certain chapters of black
lives matters certain chapters of the
Democratic socialists of America there
are going to be a lot of people on the
left who otherwise would have kind of
gone along with whatever people like
that were saying or groups like that
were saying and they're going to be like
you know what if that's what defines
progressivism in America I'm not that
and I'm moving to someplace else on the
political Spectrum